The Joe Rogan Experience the problem
with winners and losers is I'm crazy yep
and you're crazy and Bert's an [ __ ]
but it I just don't wanna I don't like
that part I don't want to open up that
[ __ ] box in my brain it's not what
part of you doesn't get my sense of
humor it's not that I don't get it I
don't care
you don't understand you think I don't
get it oh I know what you're doing
who do you think could do the most
push-ups right now in a row definitely
me you want me to start sure whatever
you do I'll do double don't say that how
many can you do in a row easy 40. he'll
think I could do 80.
prove it prove it prove it wait how long
do I have to wait in between sets
hold it right here hold it right here
though but that's how long can I wait by
the way down again keep going what is
the ghost anyone's ever done in a row I
used to be able to do a hundred I can
100 do 40 easy easy easy not easy I can
do four so I'm like if I do 40
and I Pace myself like how much time are
you allowed to hang out down there can't
stop I gotta keep it going I'll tell you
what I think you can you can you can
I've seen people pause it you can pause
it
okay let's start it let's start to hide
hello larger than me then Tom then
what's the most important to do more
than you I don't know I don't know
that's true what's the most someone's I
don't know ten thousand five hundred
shut up shut up
it's being questioned whether it's even
possible
push-ups I can [ __ ] [ __ ] up hmm your
monkey market question was just getting
your head down yeah you're gonna make me
tear a peck because
yeah go crazy and I'm not going to want
to lose to you ever in anything the
problem is here's the way it works with
uh with competition yeah so it's it's
entirely mental to tell you the silliest
thing I had a moment of a
[Music]
seven he looks like a Popeye cartoon
eight
nine
ten
all right eleven
twelve
thirteen holy [ __ ] Ari it's nice all
right 14 15
15. you get 15.
and then rest at the bottom rest of the
bottom and then throw yourself up
15 and a quarter nice all right here we
go that's pretty strong considering like
you were at six right
what was the first when you started out
would you start off the first timer arms
and then it was four after that how many
do you think I could do right now I
think you can do your 40. I don't know
are you gonna do it oh wow
I got 15. you'll be able to feel right
away whether you can do it probably
do it do it naked I don't think you need
to be now Bert what are you doing keep
that shirt on it's for propaganda wait
oh just kidding on my knees yeah you're
used to it
here he goes all right
count them out Joe
one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31 32 33. by the
way none of those count oh [ __ ] none of
those are legit all right not a single
one not a single one was legitimate oh
come on
you barely doubled me no I just stopped
because I'm not gonna do the oh those
aren't real push-up game
I don't think they're real it's a fun
game
I thought your push-ups were legit
already broken push-up let's see a Joe
Rogan push-up
I don't want to hurt myself
don't go for a hundred just do it no no
no no no no no it better be
where
wait for me real mine didn't look real
that's your belly I thought no you
didn't I know
this is a real one great
two
it's real okay
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20.
two three four five six
nine thirty
three all right four
seven eight nine forty
five nine all right fifty
all right you're good man
he's got to do 66.
so it's raining right all right 70. 70
keep going five more five more five more
four
all right wow dude [ __ ] nice
75 push-ups wow 75
oh pretty impressive
Tucker Carlson can't do that I didn't
hurt myself
I was legitimately worried for real yeah
I was gonna like I was gonna go too far
35 is a lot
good job Joe